In this lecture, we will talk about the
Internet's original design principles. These design principles were
discussed in the paper reading for today, the
Design Philosophy of the DARPA Internet Protocols, by
Dave Clark, dated 1988. The paper has many
important lessons and we will go through many
of them as we revisit many of the
design decisions. Before we jump into any details
let's talk about some of the high level lessons. One
of the most important conceptual lessons is that the design
principles and priorities were designed for a certain type of
network. And as the internet evolves, we are feeling some of
the growing pains of some of those choices. In the
last lesson. We talked about a number of the problems
and growing pains of the internet. And it's worth bearing
in mind that many of the problems that we are seeing
now, are a result of some of the original
design choices. Now that's not to say that some of
these design choices are right or wrong, but rather that
they simply reflect the nature of our understanding at the
time as well as, the environment and constraints that
the designers faced for the particular network that existed at
that time. Now needless to say, some of the technical
lessons. From the original design have turned out to be
fairly timeless. One concept is packet switching, which we
will discuss in this lesson. And another is the
notion of fate sharing, or soft state, which we
will discuss in a subsequent lesson in the course.